hello everyone and welcome to this new
video on business intelligence have you
ever wondered how companies use data to
make important decisions and improve
their operations well that's where
business intelligence comes in business
intelligence also known as bi is a set
of tools and processes that help
organizations analyze data and make
informed decisions it's like a crystal
ball that helps businesses see into the
future and make strategic decisions
based on the data analysis but how
exactly does bi work well it starts with
collecting data from multiple sources
like transaction Data customer data and
social media data this data is then
processed and analyzed using bi tools
like dashboards reports and analytical
models the insights provided by bi helps
organizations identify Trends patterns
and opportunities that they can use to
make better decisions and drive growth
so in this video we are going to take
you through the core concept of what
business intelligence is and why is it
so important but before that if you
enjoy watching such videos and find them
interesting then please subscribe to our
Channel because we bring the best videos
for you deal also hit the Bell icon to
get notified whenever we drop a new
video data present in this world is
never so are the jobs for people working
on this data to make proper insights so
if you want to enter the field of data
and make a career then the post graduate
program in business analysis in
collaboration with Purdue is clearly the
right choice for you this program helps
you learn how to tackle complex business
problems using in-demand tools and you
will make the most of most of business
analysis course with master classes from
Purdue University this postgraduate
program in business analysis is for
professionals looking to pursue a
business analysis career understand
business analysis techniques get
hands-on experience and for experienced
analysts looking to learn the latest
tools and Frameworks used by agile teams
this program will also help you master
high rated skills like business analysis
and recitation and collaboration BRD frd
and SRS document creation requirement
analysis data visualization and menu so
hurry up and enroll now the link is
mentioned in the description box below
so without any further delay let's get
started with what exactly is business
intelligence well at its core business
intelligence often referred to as bi is
the process of collecting analyzing and
transforming raw data into actionable
insights for business purposes it helps
organizations make informed decisions
enhance performance and gain a
Competitive Edge in today's Dynamic
market so let's understand the steps
involved in the processing of data the
first step in the business intelligence
process is data collection businesses
Begin by identifying the relevant data
sources for their operations such as
internal databases customer interactions
website analytics and social media
platform once identified the necessary
data is extracted from each source which
can be in various formats like
spreadsheets or databases before
proceeding it's important to cleanse the
data by removing duplicates errors or
inconsistencies ensuring its accuracy
and reliability the second step is data
integration with the collected data in
hand the next step is data integration
businesses transform the data into a
unified format that is compatible and
consistent across different data sources
this transformation involves
standardizing data formats organizing
fields and creating a unified data
structure the transform data from
various sources is then merged into a
central repository or data warehouse
serving as a single source of Truth for
further analysis and Reporting the third
step is data analysis businesses select
appropriate analysis techniques based on
their objectives which can include
exploratory data analysis statistical
modeling data visualization or machine
learning algorithms using these
techniques businesses uncover patterns
Trends and correlation within the data
these insights provide valuable
information about customer Behavior
market trends operational efficiency
product insights and more to communicate
the findings effectively businesses
create reports and visualizations that
present the insights in a clear and
understandable format the fourth step is
decision making and action the final
step in the business intelligence
journey is turning insights into actions
armed with the insights from data
analysis businesses make informed
decisions these decisions can range from
optimizing operational processes and
refining Market strategies to improving
customer experience and identifying new
business opportunities businesses
continuously monitor the impact of their
decisions and actions using feedback
loops and iterative processes to refine
strategies adapt to changing market
conditions and improve overall
performance
have you ever wondered how successful
people can be after opting a
postgraduate program in business
analytics hear it from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their careers hi I'm Cortana I live in
Raleigh North Carolina and working as a
business analyst at River tour
this is my second job since I completed
the postgraduate program in physics
analytics I simply learned with Ruchi
University in December 2021. my
experience with simplen was great the
life classes were my favorite because
they were very interactive and I could
connect with instructors
I have many small gaps and short
Employments in my career
I even have a huge two-year career Gap
due to some health issues however I
think the dark times are now behind me
it doesn't matter how challenging that
may be keep upscaling and one day you
will achieve success in life
the next question is why is business
intelligence so valuable to businesses
so let's explore its benefits the first
is enhanced decision making by providing
accurate and timely insights bi enables
organizations to make informed decisions
based on facts rather than assumptions
or intuition this leads to improved
efficiency reduced risks and better
outcomes increased operational
efficiency business intelligence
streamlines operations by identifying
bottlenecks optimizing processes and
highlighting areas of improvement this
leads to enhanced productivity cost
savings and overall efficiency gains
competitive advantage in today's
competitive landscape gaining a
Competitive Edge is crucial bi equips
businesses with actionable insights
about market trends customer preferences
and competitors enabling them to make
strategic moves and stay ahead of the
Curve
applications of business intelligence
retail bi helps retailers analyze
customer buying patterns optimize
inventory levels and personalized
marketing campaigns ultimately improving
sales and customer satisfaction
Healthcare by leveraging bi Healthcare
Providers can analyze patient data
optimize resource allocation and
identify patterns to enhance Medical
Treatments and patient outcomes
Finance bi enables financial
institutions to assess risk detect
fraudulent activities and identify
investment opportunities resulting in
improved decision making and financial
performance
let's understand the tools for business
intelligence a number of bi tools are
already present in the market but let's
go through the top business intelligence
tools power bi Microsoft's power bi
offers robust data visualization
capabilities interactive dashboards and
integration with various data sources
it's user friendly and allows for
collaboration and sharing within the
organization
W is renowned for its interactive and
intuitive data visualization features it
supports Advanced analytics custom
calculations and offers seamless
integration with multiple data sources
click view clickview provides a
comprehensive business intelligence
platform with powerful data Discovery
visualization and Reporting features it
allows users to explore data from
various angles and uncover hidden
insights look Luca offers a cloud-based
platform for data exploration and
visualization it focuses on providing
real-time insights and collaborative
analytics enabling teams to work
together seamlessly so there you have it
folks business intelligence is an
essential tool that can help businesses
succeed in today's marketplace with that
we have come to the end of this what is
business intelligence video I hope you
guys must have got a good idea about
what business intelligence is and why is
it so important for businesses in
today's world if you still have any
question or doubts let us know in the
comment section below and a team of
experts will help you at the earliest so
thank you so much for being here today
we'll see you next time until then stay
safe and keep learning with simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here